salut la team mantallot souvent sur
cette chaîne on parle d' imaginaires de
visualisation de mémoire avec des images
mais bien souvent dans les commentaires
vous me dites que c'est un petit peu
compliqué pour vous de faire travailler
votre imagination c'est pourquoi
aujourd'hui je vous fais un master class
sur la visualisation et l'imagerie
mentale
le but c'est que vous arriviez à
visualiser des choses correctement en 3d
dans votre esprit voire même les yeux
ouverts les techniques sur lesquelles je
me suis appuyé pour me former au départ
en viennent des recommandations que
faisait nikola tesla à ce sujet nicolas
tesla ça vous parle c'est un grand
inventeur il est né en 1856 en croatie
il a déposé plus de 1000 brevets il
parlait 12 langues illarine mémoire
photographique une capacité de
visualisation exceptionnel il a conçu la
plupart de ses inventions de tête dans
ce master class je vais vous donner
quatre exercices et un vrai conseil à la
toute fin c'est quatre exercices ne sont
pas des tests le but c'est pas d'essayer
de le faire est de passer au suivant il
s'agit plus d'une méthodologie que je
vous propose fait le premier exercice le
jour où vous ne maîtrisez tranquillement
à 100% alors vous pourrez passer au
deuxième exercice
idem pour ce deuxième exercice et
ensuite vous passerez au troisième
s'ils viennent bien toute la vidéo
puisque je donne un vrai conseil très
important à la fin et j'ai une petite
annonce à vous faire pour une vidéo de
la semaine prochaine pour muscler votre
visualisation le premier exercice et que
vous allez prendre une photo essayez de
l'imprimé tant qu'à faire pour l'avoir
toujours sur vous ça vous permettra de
vous entraîner n'importe où vous allez
regarder la photo et la détailler au
maximum ça prendra le temps que ça
prendra mais détaillé la photo au
maximum tous les détails tout la
luminosité et les couleurs les formes
l'organisation tous complètement ensuite
je suis sûr que vous l'avez deviné vous
cacher la photo et vous devez l'art
visualiser de tête mentalement essayez
de vous rappeler un maximum de détails
mais pas en sucre vocalisant pas en vous
parlant dans votre tête mais vraiment en
essayant de voir l'image devant vous au
départ ça risque d'être un petit peu
compliqué mais ça va venir rapidement
travailler sur la même photo jusqu'à
temps que vous arriviez à le faire
complètement à chaque fois que vous
essayez d'imaginer une fois que vous
avez fait de ce travail là vous reprenez
la photo vous essayez de voir les
détails que vous aviez oublié ou pas et
vous refaites l'exercice jusqu'à temps
que vous le maîtrisiez évidemment vous
pouvez aussi changer de photo si vous
voulez pour en prendre une plus simple
une plus compliqué pour vous tester une
fois que vous aurez maîtriser tout ça ça
va commencer à venir on va passer un
côté plus amusant vous allez prendre un
objet je vous recommande un objet
relativement simple stylo un paquet de
cartes inde et un briquet un téléphone
portable et vous allez faire le même
travail qu'avec la photo vous allez
soutenir dans vos mains vous allez le
regarde et vous allez prendre en compte
la sensation vous avez si c'est du métal
vous allez ressentir le froid par
exemple la dureté
vous devez donc le modéliser dans votre
tête mais en trois dimensions vous devez
être capable de le tourner dans votre
tête de mettre dans plein de positions
différentes
en étant capables à chaque fois de
l'imaginer dans ses moindres détails si
vous avez fait des exercices dans
l'ordre vous devriez pas avoir trop de
difficultés en tout cas pas plus qu'avec
le premier après pour vous tester vous
allez fermez les yeux vous allez essayer
de l'imaginer comme ça devant vous de
bouger un petit peu le regard des parts
au dessus par au dessous devant derrière
et là vous allez pouvoir muscler encore
plus votre visualisation faisant deux
choses la première ça va être d'essayer
de le faire les yeux ouverts vous allez
y arriver à terme vous allez y arriver
c'est sûr vous allez projeter l'image
devant vous un petit peu comme dans la
réalité augmentée à l'instar d'un
hologramme qui serait devant vous vous
allez le visualiser en superposant à la
réalité
puis toujours les yeux ouverts ou en
fermant les yeux vous allez imaginé cet
objet dans un environnement tout en
faisant agir l'environnement avec
l'objet si l'objet que je visualise par
exemple c'est un téléphone je peux
l'imaginer très près de moi ou poser au
loin sur une table mais avec le soleil
qui tape dessus donc faut que j'imagine
forcément le reflet ce qui est
passionnant c'est que votre cerveau sait
déjà tout comment les choses réagissent
si vous imaginez le soleil qui tape
comme ça vous allez avoir le bon reflet
dans votre tête votre cerveau le sait
pour passer enfin un troisième exercice
qui est le plus agréable vous allez vous
imaginez vous à la première personne au
travers de vos yeux à vous vous voyez
pas en extérieur dans un lieu précis si
possible un lieu agréable ça marche
mieux
et pour commencer par un lieu trop
complexe un lieu simple ça peut être un
champ dans lequel il ya quelques arbres
ou alors une plage sur une île déserte
vous allez vite vous rendre compte que
même dans les lieux contre ou simple il
ya quand même beaucoup beaucoup de
choses à visualiser ou alors si vous
êtes déjà commencé ce travail là voir
cette vidéo vous pouvez vous imaginer
dans votre palais mental anat mais
vraiment à l'intérieur de votre palais
mental pour commencer vous avez imaginé
tous les détails qui vous entourent mais
en utilisant réellement tous vos sens
visualiser mentalement le bruit des
oiseaux par exemple oui on peut
visualiser du bruit ressentent elles
vont essayer d'avoir les odeurs obtenez
une image complète de cette réalité avec
tous vos sens et ensuite vous allez
commencer à interagir avec cette réalité
c'est tout à fait possible
vous n'allez pas y arriver en deux jours
c'est sûr mais le jour où vous allez y
arriver ça ne s'oubliera pas et vous
serez capable de le faire pour toute
votre vie le point le plus important
l'astuce le plus importante c'est le
réalisme et le détail il faut que vous
visualisez y ait un maximum de détails
et que ce soit le plus réaliste possible
j'insiste vraiment dessus parce qu'on
confond parfois la visualisation avec le
fantasme par exemple je peux visualiser
dehors en train de courir et faire un
bain
attends je vais sûrement anticipé
quelques petites choses quelques
possibilités mais je vais me voir faire
le marathon point là on est dans le
fantasme par contre si je fais une vraie
procédure de visualisation avec tous les
détails avec l'association des
chaussures avec la sueur qui coule sur
moi avec la fatigue avec l'effort qu'on
ressent dans une montée aussi petite
soit elle avec tout le réalisme que ça
comporte
alors là ça va être bénéfique je vais
pouvoir interagir avec ça et anticiper
complètement tout mon parcours
voilà les amis je vous le dit votre
cerveau est capable de faire ça ça
demande un petit peu d'entraînement il
faut vraiment musclé ça mais en
découpant avec les trois exercices que
je vous ai donné assez rapidement vous
allez obtenir des résultats sur le
premier exercice et vous allez vite
pouvoir passer à la suite c'est vraiment
cool à faire j'espère donc vraiment que
cette vidéo vous aura plu la semaine
prochaine pour fêter les trente mille
abonnés sur la chaîne je vais faire une
petite et fac je voulais faire une faq
snap chatte et je suis en train de
changer d'opérateur en ce moment chez
moi j'ai des galères avec internet j'ai
peur de ne pas pouvoir la faire comme
jeu et comme la dernière fois on est
passé par facebook ce coup ci on va
faire une faq twitter vous avez donc
jusqu'à mercredi soir pour mieux poser
votre question sur twitter avec le
hashtag mentalisme 30000 bas au moins
c'est clair comme hashtag je vais donner
un thème pour cette faq histoire quelle
part pas dans tous les sens pour celles
ci on va se concentrer sur les vidéos
les vidéos de mentalisme et les vidéos
sur youtube vous pouvez donc me poser
n'importe quelle question sur ce sujet
là si cette vidéo vous a plu n'oubliez
pas par contre avant de partir de
laisser un gentil et très agréable et
visualisant pouce en l'air et également
de vous abonner à la chaîne en cliquant
ici ou ici parce que le mental blog
c'est une vidéo par jour depuis le 1er
janvier jusqu'au 31 décembre vous rendez
vous demain à 11 heures
ciao